[Music]  some detectives we are should've gone  with the sisters of quiet mercy weeks  ago and found this out found out what  Betty what is he doing you  I took trick down to the sheriff's  station to give a statement that I  invited him back for dinner  great except he's not chick okay enough  with the melodrama Betty he's not  Betty shut the hell up imposter took  Hadden I paid a visit to the sisters of  quiet mercy that is your real son mom  not this con artist I don't I don't  understand  I do Betty's been out to get me from the  start she never wanted a brother you're  not my brother what is this picture what  does it all mean it's what we're trying  to figure out Mrs Cooper the truth  Riverdale all-new episode tonight at  8:00 7:00 central only on the CW and the  CW app  [Music]